like there was a butcher and this guy
watched this butcher who'd been a
butcher so life and the guy watched his
butcher cut meat and it looked like his
hand was just falling through it looked
like his hand wasn't doing any effort
his hand was going like that and and and
the butcher over you know 30 years of
deep practices that figured out exactly
where to cut so that it took zero effort
where he knew exactly the salt bacon
I don't know that guy's crazy he's like
he's basic a magician but owns a steak
house he does this yeah he's amazing
mm-hmm no definitely not that guy let me
see that guy
oh you open a restaurant I think he's
got a small bay in Miami yeah he's he's
very Miami he's Turkish I believe and
he's awesome
his videos are actually was this is all
Bay as in the salt babe new syrettes or
something bay stands for before anyone
else oh I am very unhip so when you call
your your girl or boy Bay that's what it
means
mm-hmm I'm Bay he's like your legit chef
huh that's what I don't mean no [ __ ]
he's a legit butchered butcher for sure
yeah he's a stud he owns a restaurant
man
want to watch one of these of course I
want to
aha
that's the tail
[Music]
he's nice with it
sunglasses there's something calming
about it the other is he's cooking he's
got sunglasses is here so no Liam just
feathering it feather food rupees you
see baby slow motion dead serious
makes a mustache work and then the
famous that's his famous salt drop no
heard them all
that's exactly how Jordan shoots Oh
final n1 n1 28.4 mil as well he should
let me get a little more this guy and
he's probably at his restaurant and he's
just this guy made a career out of
salting well yeah he did a tit he didn't
petition dude he couldn't be more of a
Miami cause you know like a brick
[ __ ]
by the way Turks are great wrestlers
macho people apparently good butchers he
got you just got famous doing that that
some you eating yeah meat and salt well
he's a butcher or slash bodybuilder Oh
like magician he's got a great sense of
humor is really what he's about
look at his hand yes all that [ __ ] up
now what
[Music]
Oh what the [ __ ] is this nothing it's
easy easy
ah it's a tiny hole isn't slicing nice
your chef you're saying he's not
magician he's a god no oh dude all he's
making it dad sir there's something
relaxing about this well it's because
he's doing nothing else there's the
LeBron little burg because there's
nothing there's a lot of effort that
goes yeah and he's doing easy just
totally focused
there's pictures of Connor at his
restaurant I love all the celebs yeah oh
yeah mm-hmm
and he has like really really hot chicks
that he lets feed oh they let him feed
her yes he's he fancies himself a king I
wonder how tall he is my feeling is low
man this moment five-state yeah my
feeling is he's when you're 60 you don't
need to do this is this chicken-fried
steak
it looks like you're right this
schnitzel I never under had a shoe I'm
gonna go ahead and say he's very short
but who cares chin see if he's close to
any celebrities it's a picture so I can
I do I bet that [ __ ] is fire Pete no
vegans please here we go well here's the
salt bay Oh
make it rain to make it it's snowing
it's wintertime well I realize that's
very good cooking she's got a whole lot
salty yeah
sodium anybody what we asked him right
see how tall he is I want to try to find
with others will go to celebrity horn
scroll down chin go to Reyes pictures
him and celebrities you'll be oh if we
can find him he posted with him all the
time yeah I see him online all the time
you fall on chin no but he always pops
up in my Explorer there's probably like
six two six three
okay well that guys wearing lifts dr. oz
yeah I'm telling this guy's really yeah
yeah there's dj khaled I don't know what
that is
Tom of these because therefore which one
for left yeah yeah he's not at all
Champions League well we just go to
height you think it's on there i just
google it he's not famous
he's Instagram famous different animal
you know mm-hmm too soft a high five
point five five five yeah and that son
here's his pre-fight three he's not a
talker no it's part of what drives him P
Diddy where same as out the pone though
yeah I don't know what that is
he looks like Armand de santé they just
try you know just doing the damn thing
Halloween I make sense oh I would like
to try his food okay - it'd be fun
what's it called
is it salt days salt bay restaurant I
don't think so here's a couple of
restaurants I know yes well the one in
Miami's the main where all the celebrity
know steak houses it's also a fait la
notice that it's called the salt bay
restaurant interesting job in New York -
mm-hmm and it's a five-star diamond
award restaurant well it's fantastic
yeah I love America will you come in
with an idea on Instagram and you end up
building a whole thing yeah nice yeah it
does now else we do know a steakhouse
it's good I'm gonna sneak a sweet
Houston was it being be butchers yeah
Stan outstanding amazing project I don't
know of any good rep people send us good
steak house in San Antonio I don't know
any I just kind of stay on campus there
yeah
would be nice to go to state jobs maybe
I might be all you need let's take out
campus I'll tell you this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]